alright let's go for it yeah I don't
know what this story is when is it from
but I thought it would be fun to talk
about America's weight profit very 22nd
2018 it says here what is the average
weight for women now I'm not trying to
single out women you know with this
segment yeah what's it really it has
nothing to do with women in general
because Americans are overweight right
that is a simple fact what this leads to
a very important point about modern
politics that I think we can talk about
ok body positivity anti fat shaming I'll
have you have you heard of this stuff
yeah of course
okay here's what here I'll tell you
exactly why I think it exists first you
know the Dove real beauty campaign they
did yeah Dove soap
mm-hm if you guys didn't see it it's
basically like a bunch of regular
looking women I'm not gonna say they're
overweight it was like plus size and
regular bodies and they were making a
point about how not every woman is a
model and yet they got models dove
overweight models to do it for sure
dove is owned by Unilever Unilever owns
Ben & Jerry's I know it's a bit funny
but I'm being serious
well do you know like same people that
own Ben & Jerry's well not Ben & Jerry's
per se but like some dairy products they
also own like like the anti indigestion
medicine right that dairy causes but
this way well like imagine you had a a
like shop like a stand on a street
corner yeah and you sold you know like a
health food but also a bowl of ice cream
right how do you make sure your customer
wants to buy both you don't want to
undercut your ice cream by saying like
the health food is important because ice
cream is bad for you so you've got to be
like actually this granola health bar is
excellent when broken up and put in the
ice cream because you try to sell both
right exactly so that was actually a
funny meme where the idea was why would
Unilever trying to undercut their
businesses they want women to feel good
being overweight so they do a campaign
for on this side that way they don't
feel bad when they go any tons of ice
cream but I don't you wanna you want out
you want to read this one let's say no I
really don't you know what I read it I
don't I this this this article almost
frightens me
the
because of that it's like well it's
targeting women for for one which
doesn't really make sense because I feel
like everyone has has a weight issue
it's true it's not a woman thing I think
it's just over consumption in general
yeah in the state it's like we just over
consume everything you know and I but
here's but here's the thing what's up
I'm like look we pulled this article I
think the main focus I want to talk
about is like overweight America yeah in
other countries mm-hmm but I do think
it's fair to point out the body
positivity stuff is coming from women
not men that's true and we don't see
about it body positivity for men where's
where dead bodies are actually like more
sought after I read this article about
it because women see a dead body and and
think of their dad well no no not that
they are they think financial financial
stability right because they're
consuming food and they've they can like
support themselves support themselves I
don't know if this is true but I read
that and I was like wow that's semester
that's like when beautiful right yeah
yeah like you know that's why women
those country where they're like whoa
the big woman is like well here's the
thing look my goodness they do these
things where like you know birds of prey
for instance okay Cassandra Cain was
played by H like you know a chubby
overweight little asian girl hmm and
they do that because they're like what
does it matter buddy but but but you
don't see that like when are we gonna
have you know a fat Iron Man right it's
the it's always like if it's the man
it's fine
yeah so they complete what this makes me
really mad because that's because the
body positivity ladies will literally
tell you that they are not attracted to
what is correctly called overweight men
yeah
really plus-sized ladies feel just fine
saying they're no way attracted to men
that are called overweight the men are
not called plus-sized right yep they're
overweight plus-sized men and women are
plus-sized plus-sized men but then you
see these viral posts where it's like a
woman will say something like no short
men there's there's a viral tinder post
where the woman put their profile being
like if you're under six feet don't
bother yeah and then a guy commented if
you're over 150 don't bother and then
she got really angry and he was like
it's just
like nothing right no well yeah you can
choose to be skinny change your weight I
did it I've maintained a 50 pounds
that's it great that's a great point
you're right you can't change your with
your height a mess yeah yeah well I was
born in a certain height well
technically can't you break your legs
and like have them extend but then your
legs are getting bigger in your torso is
not proportionate so that's true yeah
let's right let's pull this article they
say what is the average weight for women
women knowing if your weight is within a
healthy range can be beneficial this is
particularly so in United States where
obesity is a significant problem
American women aged 20 years and above
weigh an average of 106 170 point six
pounds so much I weigh that's crazy
and there's one five foot three women
and I'm 6 foot loneliness according to
CDC height-wise the average adult female
is 5 foot 3 inches and her waist
measures 38.2 inches we got problems man
well and they did those I feel like
those are the people that are going to
Burger King and going oh well I can have
the impossible burger exactly better for
me yeah it's like so so words not Burger
King launches the vegan burger and then
people show up to Burger King to get
there it's not vegan well right because
I cook it on the grill right but they
they go to get the not the meat plant
basis and little like better is this is
the joke where they're like and then
they get the massive coca-cola Super
King size diet huge fries the diode diet
soda right yeah actually I think Family
Guy did a joke about this a tub we're
like a really big fat person goes to the
shop and they're like I'll get the
triple double cheeseburger you know or
the triple double bacon with the extra
large fry double salt and oh I should
get diet it's like does it matter at
this point this point now I will stop I
will stop if you choose to be fat I got
no problem with you right I just want to
pay for your triple bypass exactly so
you get these people saying like we
should have you know free health care
it's like okay government health care
yes I love it but that we have to
maintain some kind of health program
right exactly anything that's not
healthy to be overweight but so there's
a point where plus size becomes
overweight and
worry where is that line I mean and
morbidly obese sure I mean there but
there you
there there is a healthy you know you
can have a healthy amount of fat on you
right you know you don't have to be a
twig a twig yeah exactly it's like there
is a healthy point so this and then it
becomes an unhealthy point what's to
think about this you have all America so
think about how how overweight everyone
is and if you choose to do so again I'm
all about freedom yeah eat the Twinkies
to your heart's delight but the people
who are arguing that the government
should cover all healthcare mm-hmm and
we should pay for it at the same time
there's they're promoting unhealthy
lifestyles it's like do you have any
look if you want to talk about health
care being three trillion dollars a year
maybe hey it blows me away too because
it's like I see yogurt commercials and
I'm just like yeah terrible for you
yogurts like ice cream a little
realizing yeah it's not it's not healthy
well now from what I've I've seen no no
here's the thing you know ice creams not
bad for you too much ice cream is bad
for you yeah yogurt is not bad for
yogurts goodreads got acidophilus got
those you know there's one other thing
good pro bono but you can get those
outside yogurt also you can but you can
have some yogurt look I do those little
tiny like you know two ounce yogurts
every day no other probiotics so some
you know I think you're a big you know
anti dairy guy well I mean I just have
done a lot of research and I know a lot
about the what it does to the human body
so I don't care if you eat dairy fine
eat your dick you don't want fine but I
I don't want to because I know what it
causes specific things and I know these
dairy companies are owning the medicines
that counteract that exact same thing
too because they know that dairy it's
just like Unilever it's groaning the
real beauty campaign and selling ice
cream it's the same thing but here's
what I want to say the whole mark well I
believe this like a cycle to convince
you that it's ok the problem isn't the
little itty bitty yogurts I drink every
day
the problem is these women go out and
get those cups of Chobani which is Greek
yogurt stuffed with sugar and and and
fruit and like I'm meeting with an extra
bit of sugar and ice on top of it yeah
got the cookie bits and that's so
interesting to me I've never seen more
obese people to know when I went to
Whole Foods and I'm like all of these
people think that they're eating healthy
because they're buying organic food and
they are still eating it too much yeah
and then you look at like how many
servings it is like force
servings in that one Chobani thing and
it's like what they're just letting it
out I would I would eat the whole thing
I went to the store and I pulled up a
pint of Ben & Jerry's and a cup of joe
Bonnie and I compared them mm-hmm and
they're like very similar
I'm sure tons of sugars yeah its tons of
fat it's just the yogurt isn't frozen
and whipped for your delight yeah so now
we end up with here chickens that we
have this list here does it say at a
hundred and seventy seven point nine
pounds the average body mass in North
America is the highest of any continent
continent worldwide according to a 2005
statistics published in 2012 by BMC
public health North America also has the
highest percentage of people who are
overweight with seventy three point nine
thirty seventy percent whoa Wow yeah I
remember being in gym class you know and
you get that little thing that pinches
the like underside of your head alike
sama and it tells you is that considered
fat shaming now if they do that probably
it's like oh no no no we have a couple
overweight kids stop sure you know if we
do that they'll be like embarrass that
they're fat it's like California they
ditch the fitness test or maybe and
maybe some of them will start working
out because they didn't realize that
they were overweight because they were
taught and grew up in an environment
that led them to that that way and then
maybe they'll get wise and actually
start working out lies Asia doing so
good
what's up with that no actually was
reading something it's really it's
really hard to eat out rotating the
America yeah like in America you know
one of the problems we got is that's
true never go to a diner Oh an American
diner get food everywhere dude there's a
diner over here and you go in there and
you're like I'll get the fish and chips
and they bring you a platter for a
family for one person that's true yeah
and I'm like but there's seven real odd
filets and a gallon of french fries in
front of me and I can't eat this and
then people eat it goes in front of them
and they just start you know losing it
well the diner that I found is a vegan
one well they have a happy they have a
the head chef is vegan so like they have
like a nice solid vegan section which is
which is so cool but
the portions are great you know like
every time I've eaten there it's like
eight it's irrelevant about the vegan
thing it's about the proportions right
you know it's like it's a cool diner
they did over salt some things I just
mean like in general I was talked to him
about it and they've it's been better
okay now that I've been going and
they've eaten the different things so
it's like the proportions at this place
are pretty on point and I don't almost I
don't know what the nutrition
information is on these meals that I'm
eating you know I don't I'm not like hmm
what's the salt content and how much
have salt have I had today you know yeah
like I I don't do that you know and I am
I would consider myself fit but I don't
okay soon you know I eat when I'm hungry
I walk and skate and still I'm place it
I just ate way too much so I need to fix
my habits for sure I mean I don't know
what I'm not saying I know what the
answers are for anybody you know but
here's here's some specific statistics
that were 73% overweight seventy-nine
percent it's like not almost 74 percent
of Americans are overweight like that's
that's a crazy and you know it's that
making it worse is the the the body
positivity stuff look man you don't
gotta be mean to somebody like you know
Milo gianopolous posted a picture have
fat shaming a dude in the gym and I'm
like just mean I'm like were you doing
like they got you you literally the guys
at the gym you've one trying to do some
writing about it you've won Yeah right
exactly what are you trying to do there
now you're I asked about it and he said
well he should do it at home it's
disgusting
or something like that and those those
are the people that I'm like oh you're
serious
yeah right yeah you're gonna get you're
just trying to appeal to the other
people that are also a oles that are
gonna laugh at that right more clickbait
just you know that's all it is it's like
the opposite of virtues signaling you
know bully signaling or something I
don't know yeah you know like in a sense
there there are sadistic people out
there that just get a get a kick out of
all this
yeah and that's and you know why it will
suck and there are a lot of people who
want to watch that I know people get mad
at me sometimes for not being mean and
angry and certain you know things are
individual so huh because I'm fairly
ambivalent like I'll tell you this man
look the facts are clear I'm all down to
get right behind you Bernie Sanders and
talk about that Medicare for all but
only if you can deal with the fact that
people right now are
liberating unhealthy lifestyles that's
how you're to pay for that man yeah I
don't want to pay so I'll tell you one's
operation like they drink you know two
liters of soda every day for 20 years
yep you know and now they're they're
huge and need a triple bypass surgeries
so they they can't physically eat more
the best part is in our private health
care because you don't think about in
our private system if you want to drink
two liters a two litre breakfast lunch
and dinner
mm-hmm you want to gain 200 pounds and
you're gonna pay for your own health
care that's the great thing right
nobody's gonna do it for you yeah I'm
like I'm honestly getting can write sort
of the other side of it there is so you
know that's one of the biggest
challenges we have as a nation we
simultaneously of people they're
actually shaming you if you call it
unhealthy like that that's what they're
doing they're saying you're shaming me
no no you're shaming me for trying to
tell you to be healthy it's like they're
shaming us for saying that movie was bad
it's like no the movie was bad it was
it's my opinion go away
yeah it was my opinion they were like it
by there was there was this thing that
happened that I saw it where a news
anchor went viral for calling out a man
who fat shamed her it's like first of
all some guy sent an email and he said I
think your lifestyle is unhealthy and
you're a role model for young girls so
you need to lose weight to show them you
know blah blah and she got offended by
it
the dude wasn't this wasn't mean he was
being blunt like little girls watching a
pretty boy yeah so she decides to
broadcast his email and be like I will
not stand for this I had four kids and
so what if I'm overweight and then
everyone went like yeah slay Queen you
go girl all that stuff and I'm like hold
on man
if you can't privately tell someone
bluntly but not disrespectfully well
there's a good reason why you little I
mean nah I don't know there's it's like
who is he who is he to tell her that
though
daughters he has every right to ask her
privately okay he wasn't being mean I
could I mean I could see it but there
you know it could be seen as like you
know alright
he didn't say like hey Gordo if wants to
put down the Twinkie but that make
that's a good point though had he maybe
he's got daughters if that's probably
why he was like hey you know my daughter
watches the show and he's just look I
could wait I can see both sides
we're now in a place where it's like
it's it's it's bigoted it's it's
privileged it's it's a shaming yeah to
say to someone something so there was a
thing happened in the UK they had a an
ad on a bus stop it said the biggest
cause of cancer is and then it rolls
over says obesity and there's a huge out
roar like you're shaming us it's like
but it's true yeah look I'll say it
again the problem with the UK is they
have a National Health Service mm-hmm so
I can totally understand why people in
the UK are gonna be like go lose weight
why am I paying for you to eat you know
triple cheeseburgers and fish and chips
every every 20 minutes exactly so I mean
that's probably of the biggest hurdles
but perhaps I should just end by saying
look man if you get if you get angry
because people you know point out that
it's unhealthy I think you're secretly
insecure that makes sense like the only
reason you're insecure is because only
reason you're upset is because you know
it's true yeah I'll tell you what
triggers I've talked to people who get
to spend you know go into autodefense
mode yep I've talked to people and I've
these kinds of conversations who were
fat and they were just laughing about it
and they're kind of like having a normal
conversation they get bent to the shape
and their and their attitude was just
like yep don't care I know all about it
yep things when people react like that
they are they feel maybe guilty well
yeah we are a fat country thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to
subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next show
you